Muslims
[Silence]
asking you teach me about Islam and then
you just frown a little bit on your face
because you want to convince somebody
who's not a not Muslim to be entering
Islam. Allah reminds the person who came
to you who is Muslim is more important
to you the person who's already not a
Muslim. Your responsibility is not that
person who is not a Muslim yet. We
haven't got it
backwards. There's not one hadith or
several hadith that point out to us this
that Allah subh has said whoever has
kib in his heart will not enter the
paradise and don't twist that words
either. Don't twist them that that you
know that person not enter paradise.
Allah will punish them or he can forgive
them from his mercy. But that's
kibber that magn magnificence or the the
mightiness only belongs to who? Allah
subhana
tala. Alibria is is is a a a a subh.
It's a it's a it's a it's a
characteristic of Allah subhana
tala. Me and you cannot try to get close
to it. Yes, we can close to we can come
to close to you know
being Abdul Rahman and Abdahim by having
mercy upon people by feeding people by
taking care of them but we
cannot race one against each other try
to come close to Allah subhana tala in
his
magnificence if we pay attention Allahh
has mentioned In the
Quran, Allah is reminding us, look how
many magnificent palaces and fountains
and gardens they left behind and how
many corn fields and the palaces they
had and they were enjoying all these
goodness in their lives and they were
talking about these things. Look at my
stuff and look at my stuff.
Allah says, "We take that and give it to
somebody
else." But to me in those in those four
or five ayats, the most important ayah
is that last one Allah
says, "And then the earth or the or the
the heavens and the earth did not shed a
single tear for them when they died.
All those structures we have created,
all those things we have, the idea is to
use it to get closer to Allah subhana
tala, not get further away from Allah
subhanaa tala and let that not be a
deterrence between me and my brother as
a
Muslim. The famous hadith
ofam, you see a man come to the masid
and pray, give shahada that he is a
Muslim.
That's
it. My job, your job is not to go and
ask and figure out what kind of Muslim
the person
is. That's ego. That's
ns. I need to look at myself, what my
shortcomings are before I go start
looking at other people and their
shortcomings.
May Allah give me shifat. I've been
suffering for a couple of
days. And then our brother Tamimi u the
father of teacher who teaches upstairs
he actually gave and came and gave a
lecture prayer from Jordan. He's also
not feeling well. Allah give
him and all our brothers and sisters who
are suffering from any health ailment. I
mean this idea of having a higher
self is an idea that is told to us in
the Quran and Allahh quotes the
I am your Lord the highest. And we see
that today. We see that in every society
today. There is this race of how can be
I more can I be more extravagant or be
more egotistic about
things and we don't care about that to
be honest with you. They can't be as
egotistic as they want to be. Our focus
is in our communities within
ourselves. When we are present, when
we're coming to the masid, we should be
embracing of one and
all. Our ego should be checked out at
the
door. Omar used to say, I welcome and I
pray for the person who comes and tells
me my
shortcomings. And by the way, don't take
that as a blanket statement as well,
please.
We're talking about constructive
criticism, not criticism for the fact of
criticism because we have that a lot
too. But why did you why did you mention
this topic? You should have mentioned
something else. It's okay. Don't worry
about
it. Our job is to build communities. Our
job is to make sure that we are not
being decisive with each other. Our job
is to make sure our brother next to us
stays on the dean of Islam and he
doesn't leave because of my attitude or
my
words. How can you twist the words of
Allah subhana tala and bring it to be
that if Allah gives haya from Allah
subhana tala but the person has left the
deen because you were the one who
instigated something with him.
We ask Allah subhana tala to make us one
from the people who unite whom and not
divide whom. We ask
Allahha to make us the way of people to
enter paradise.
We ask Allah subhana ta that he makes us
from the people who listens to his words
and act upon it and make make us a a
a lighthouse in the darkness for our
brothers and sisters who are currently
lost in Islam.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah.
in a hadith
mentioned in Abu
Dah
that said, "May Allah subhah be pleased
with him that I
heard say that Allah
has
said the the the pride is my cloak and
greatness is my robe and whoever
competes with me in the respect of their
of them I shall cast him into hellfire.
It was related to Abu D as well and Maj
as I mentioned
earlier. Understanding that the only
person who has the right to be that
entity or being that is the creator
Allah subhana
tala because
truly he is the power of all dominion.
He is the creator of all dominion.
He is the source of light and everything
that we see
today. We are all created by Allah
subhana tala and the world we see is
created by him. Every single thing that
we have around us is given to us from
Allahh. That includes all the science
and technology you see all the
advancements that you see is from
allahhala. Is nothing that we as humans
have come up on something that is nowal
or out of the realm of Allahhaala. I
always mention this quote
from he used to mention if Allah subhana
ta becomes angered with me and he
decides to throw me out of his dominion
where can he throw me that's not part of
his
dominion right if if if you do
something on the mid grounds of the
property and it's displeasing we might
trespass you but the trespass only
happens to be the the property of us. We
cannot trespass you from the entire
county or the
city. But if Allahh chooses to trespass
you, where can he throw you or bar you
from that is not his
dominion? Every single thing is created
by Allah subhana
tala. As I mentioned last week, you
know, during my my thing for for some of
the Sufis, they even say if Allah puts
us in jahannam, that's fine too because
jahannam his creation too.
I'm not saying we want to go there.
Subhan Allah. Just bear with me. Allah
has enough to put in Jannam. Allah make
us not from those people. But I'm just
talking about them saying it's a saying,
right? You understand? Even jannam is
created by
Allah. There's nothing in that we can
imagine or come up with that is not the
dominion of Allahh. So how can we be
egotistic? How can we have this ego,
this ns that speaks up when you know
that
The person who gets the last, he gets
the last person to get out of Jahannim.
The last person who was allowed to have
Jenna, his ja will be probably the size
of this earth. Even greater than
that just the size of the earth is the
the smallest Jenna is given
away man. You know if you have two acres
mashallah you you know you pounder says
I got two acres I live in two acres or
three acres or five acres or I have 50
acres. Imagine what is 50 acres compared
to the
earth. As much as we we love to travel
and we go every place else in the world,
can you cover the entire world? Can you
cover the entire globe? No, you
cannot. So what is it that we are so
arrogant about?
Ali used to say that he is surprised on
the condition of a man who carries his
waist all day in his belly. Then he sits
upon the waist to release it and then he
walks around arrogantly says that I am
everything. As one of the hadith
mentioned, we are all children of Adam
and Adam was from dust. And that's our
end.
We're here and then we're going to end
back to
dust. But if we envision today, if your
vision and my vision is for a community
that is coherent and cohesive, then we
have to put down these barriers between
us. We have to go above those barriers.
We have to stand tall and
firm and put down this pettiness that we
have with each other. Allah subhana t is
not going to ask me or ask you about the
iman or the level of e of somebody else.
Allah is going to ask me about
my he will not ask me about of somebody
else in the
congregation. The question will be on me
if I
delivered. That's it for us to deliver
the message. The guidance comes from
Allahh. Your job and my job is to make
sure that our hearts are clear with each
other. I've mentioned this before. I
mentioned it again. Subhan Allah. You
see when you hug your brother, his heart
fills the empty void in your chest over
here and your heart fills the empty void
in his chest. And that's how it's
supposed to be. May Allah subh make us a
true example of the community he wants
us to be and the community that Allah
sallall alaihi wasallam wanted and
promoted in the Medina and everywhere
else.
We ask Allah subhanaa tala to make us
from the people who unite and not
divide we ask Allahh to make us from
the people who mend hearts and not break
hearts. We ask Allah subhana tala to
make us from the people on the day of py
who are entered into paradise without
any accountability. We ask Allah subhana
tala to first and foremost protect this
community here of Muslims in this area
and everywhere else in the US. We ask
Allahhaala those brothers and sisters of
us who are suffering in the prisons
without any allegations. May Allahh
bring them home safely and soundly.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
of Sudan Kashmir of Pakistan.
[Silence]
Please move forward. There's empty
chairs around on the corner. Please move
them. Make some
space. for
[Silence]
Strain your lines from the gaps in
between. May Allah subh mercy upon us.
Amen.
Allahbar. Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Amen.
Allelujah. for
[Silence]
Allahbar. Allah.
Allahbarb.
Alhamdulillah. Foreign
[Silence]
Morning.
Amen. I love you.
[Silence]
Allah send me Allah.
Allahbar. Allahbar.
Thank you.
[Silence]
My dear brothers and sisters, asalamu
alalaykum, couple of quick
announcements. First one of
alhamdulillah, lot of kids are
graduating and I want to congratulate
all of you the kids that are graduating
this this season and
congratulation to their parents also.
Now I remind you that we have a
beautiful summer program here in the
masjid inshallah and that is going to be
for starting the June the for the
ages from a 2 and a half to 5 years age
and it's going to be starting in u on
the June the 2nd inshallah again June
the 2nd the program is available for the
kids from a two and a half to five to
eight years inshallah So brother Imam
Hassan has all the details. Please
enroll your kids. Also the Rahma Academy
is I'm providing the educational
opportunities for the infant care all
the way to the fourth grade now
inshallah. And please make sure you take
make use of that program plan for it.
There are some scholarships
available. So please talk to brother
Ahmed Jabber or Imam Hassan and we'll
make sure that we are taken care of
inshallah. now one housekeeping thing
that I to talk about a little bit
is yes I imam Hassan talked about
driving carefully around the masid and
that is very vital. The other extension
to that is if you have a vehicle that is
a big vehicle not ordinary regular
vehicle that's you know 18-wheer
some people try to bring those to the
masjid. Now, it is a neighborhood, so it
is not permissible to bring your
18-wheeler to the masjid. As much as we
love you, we just want to make sure we
don't break the the the the roads around
our masjid. And also disturb our
neighbors. If you have a vehicle that
has a leak in the oil or it drops some
oil when you park, please do not park it
on the neighbor's parking lot. So, those
are the things that are very, very
important. Please help us out.